different accounts to post these videos like on, you know, porn
website. They're insane defendants. So the So sometimes just
even on some of these crazy cases, it's just like the max statutory
payout, which is 150k. Um, and then sometimes there's punitive
stuff assessed, but the punitive stuff assessed is like for incredibly
malicious behavior, but maybe a combination of like reading Kiwi
Farms and a combination of reading everything else. Maybe Pixie
has in her mind like, "Oh my god, like he acted so atrociously
and maliciously and like I think this is all intentional." And
was like, "The [__] you're never convincing anyone
of this and it's just [__] So, I don't know. Or and
then on the last um the last thing is maybe in her mind because
I'm probably going to end up spending a lot more on this um than
what she could have asked for, maybe I'll just settle with her
because I'm um maybe I'll just settle because I want to avoid
the legal costs. So, maybe that was what she was. But I I would
rather I will pay two times more in legal cost than settling
something like this because [__] that. the idea of
somebody getting like a like the easy next 10 or 20 years on
their life by doing some insane unhinged [__] like
this. I'm good on that. But anyway, okay. There you go. Cut.
There you go. Have fun. Uh Carlos and Joan or whatever uh listening
to this whole VOD cuz I know how much you guys love to type [__]
up in your motions and throw them into court papers by listening
to my stream combos. How much you think plaintiff believed the
insane lies on her Substack or still believes? I don't think
she believed any of those. I think she knew all of that was [__]
There's no shot that we're friends for five years and then she
immediately hardcore insta super ultra rewrites every single
that's just impossible. I don't believe that. Do you think that
she was genuinely suicidal or was it an attempt to manipulate
you? Um I mean this is like double hearsay. I don't um in the
video of um in the video that was posted on was it Professor
Sunday or I'm sorry not professor Sunday. President Sunday's
channel. Oh [__] Wait a second. Oh wait, hold on.
What is there a link to like the thing that I published? Wait,
I just realized something. I despite the fact that everybody
claims otherwise because people think I'm legitimately I guess
people really do think or some people I think I don't know if
it's my haters or what think I'm actually insanely [__]
arrogant. Um I do pass [__] by I pass everything
I publish but my lawyers first. Some people like I bet he's I
bet he's stupid enough to think that he's smarter than his lawyers
and does like [__] no. I'm not I'm not [__]
[__] Why would I even risk that? A pretty good assessment
of how smart I am. I would never risk anything that stupid. But
I just realized I wonder sometimes am I referencing things that
I put in a first draft of a statement and not the actual thing
that got published. Now um where is the um I made a public I
made like a when I did like my mini festo. Did I ever link that
publicly anywhere? Oh wait, hold on. Okay, hold on one second.
Okay. So, the main things that make me wonder, so like for instance,
when Pixie was talking to people that she knew that I was in
contact with, she's saying things like, um, this is where I believe
the extortion [__] is like pretty clearly maps on,
right? I'm going to decide my next course of action of what to
do with him or with myself and him based on how the conversation
goes with you. Unless you decide you don't want to talk to him.
basically have my plans and course of action paused and we'll
choose something depending on if he agrees he has to make up
slrepent for the action and wants to work with me to find a way
to do that or if he doesn't feel that way I don't want to talk
to him myself because I feel like I tried explaining what little
anxious voice telling me to prepare for the worst I'll have to
start thinking of more extreme/nuclear options to deal with but
I'm trying to avoid spiraling down basically that and I think
the next part of this message it's basically saying that like
don't worry I won't kill myself immediately I'll wait for the
holidays or whatever basically saying like depending on how my
conversation goes with Arerodite um if it's a bad conversation
she'll kill herself But the weird thing was, and I don't have
access to these messages firsthand, but I'm sure they'll be produced
in Discovery because that's how this works, right? Were her messages
to Aaron or I'm sorry. So, this is like double hearsay. These
are Aaron Aaron's messages to President Sunday saying Pixie was
threatening to kill herself to him, but she told me this wasn't
serious. It was just to get his attention. So, like I said, I've
had the feeling that this has kind of been like a plot since
at least December 9th, but like that's this would be like a pretty
big conspiracy. And like I've said before that I generally I
don't usually believe in like big conspiracy stuff without like
a lot of evidence because it's just it's it would be pretty fantastic
for that to happen. But I don't know. I feel like I've seen a
lot of weird [__] and there's like a lot of connecting
stuff that is moving in a certain direction and yeah. But hey,
you know, who knows? We'll see. The most damning [__]
part or I'm sorry, the most damning part in my opinion is that
she was baiting people to talk about the uh not the I'm sorry,
the tape on Twitter, archiving replies and then deleting the
tweets. Yes, that is very weird. Yeah, but okay. All right, we're
moving on. Good times, fun times. She says she only went public
because the president of Sunday's video, so that was just a lie.
Yes, that was a total lie. Um, but I show that in my um I think
I show that in my manifesto video because she claims that she
had to go public as a result of that. But if you see the leaked
messages from um if you see the leaked messages from Aaron, you
can see in those messages that I think like 11 days before any
video was published, Pixie already had the entire Substack written
and she was shopping it around for opinions. So, nobody forced
her to go public with that. That's a lie. She just says that
to make it seem like she was forced maybe to defer damages that
she would have um acrewed on her own or something. But, how are
messages in Discovery proven to be real without platform confirmation?
Uh, I mean, you just you take them to be true. Um, if somebody's
producing a message closest to its original form, then you just
assume it's true. I If it was like a criminal case, you might
be a lot more um stringent about things. But, I mean, if I submit
something, someone's like, I don't trust this. It's edited. Then
I mean I guess we can I don't know what you want to do at that
point because any anything literally can be edited. I can bring
a witness to testify that it's a true or real message if you
want. But I mean will either side subpoena Discord? Um yeah that's
already been attempted but the problem is those subpoenas are
are disgustingly overreaching and they're going to need the consent
of the other party and there's no world where I consent to have
every single explicit image and video ever sent or received by
my account to the other party. That's [__] that's
disgusting and unhinged. Silence means Okay. Apparently, this
dude is some random small YouTuber who made this Idubbbz video
and apparently it was really well received. This guy's got 29,000
subs. It's got over 600,000 silence views. Let me see how other
stuff first. Hold on. Doom train. The makers are still not responding.
Defenses to be breached. Target. Damn, he's got a cape. Weaponry
deployed and a shield. Confirmed. The slayer has been activated.
Oh [__] Are they doing parrying stuff or can you
just spam
I wonder how the parrying [__] is going to work.
They didn't the um the shotgun hook. Uh that wasn't in the first
Doom, right? They they introduced that in the second one. It's
crazy. The first Doom played so well. It was in the first one.
Oh, okay. Wait, no, that was only an eternal. How am I getting
contradictory answers? Okay, it wasn't in the first. Okay. Yeah,
the first one still played really well and then they added that
hook in the second one which also played really well. Premium
edition downloadable content. Has there ever in the history of
all of mankind been a single person ever to be excited about
getting a digital art book? Oh my go Oh my god, I got the coolest
PDF. Feel like the cool thing was getting like physical art books,
but you